[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE COLEMAN:
Organizations today
are looking for
ways to streamline
the migration of existing
applications to Kubernetes.
In this video, we're going
to look at a couple offerings
from Google Cloud
that can drastically
reduce the complexity around
getting existing workloads
running in Kubernetes--
Migrate for GKE
and GKE Autopilot.
Let's start with a brief
overview of GKE Autopilot.
Kubernetes is
extremely powerful,
but can be a challenge to
setup and manage by yourself.
Provisioning and managing
resources, security and network
configuration, and scaling
can all be challenging.
To help alleviate
some of these issues,
Google Cloud has long offered
Google Kubernetes Engine
as a managed service.
By using GKE in standard
mode, customers still
provision and manage the
underlying infrastructure,
but the vast majority
of the configuration
is handled by Google.
This is a great
solution for customers
who still want to maintain
a degree of control--
for example, if they want
to use GPU instances.
However, for customers who want
to run mainstream workloads
and don't want to worry about
configuring infrastructure,
Google Cloud recently
introduced GKE Autopilot.
With Autopilot mode
clusters, customers
don't have to worry about
the underlying infrastructure
at all.
Google Cloud essentially becomes
your site reliability engineer,
scaling the cluster
up and down as needed.
You simply choose which
workloads need to run there,
and Google Cloud does a bunch
of the heavy lifting for you.
GKE Autopilot provides several
key benefits to customers.
First, optimize production
like a Kubernetes expert.
Google creates
clusters according
to battle-tested and
hardened best practices that
yield optimized
configuration and security
posture, ready for
production, helping
you reduce GKE learning curve
and get to production faster.
Strong security posture.
Google takes full responsibility
for nodes and infrastructure
security, eliminating
infrastructure security
management tasks.
Reduce day 2 operations.
Google monitors the entire
Autopilot cluster-- control
plane, worker nodes, and core
Kubernetes system components--
ensuring your pods
are always scheduled.
Improve resource efficiency.
Google takes full responsibility
for optimizing your resource
consumption.
You pay only for the
pods, not for the nodes.
So you have an easy way to run
Kubernetes with GKE Autopilot.
How can you easily get existing
workloads onto those clusters?
For those of you not familiar
with Migrate for GKE,
this solution can be
a really useful tool
in your app modernization tool
set to accelerate and simplify
your enterprise's application
modernization journey to GKE.
You have the option
to use Migrate for GKE
as is to accelerate your
end-customer modernization
or build your proprietary
automations on top
of the product to
increase productivity
of your modernization projects.
Either way, it can
drastically reduce
the time it takes
to move workloads
from VMs into containers.
When looking at migrating
an existing workload,
there are four discrete steps
that you'll want to go through.
First is discovery
and assessment.
Migrate has a fit
assessment tool
that can be used
to help identify
what workloads you have
running and which are the best
candidate for migration.
Look into the fit
assessment tool
video for more information.
Next is setup and planning.
Migrated workloads
can run on GKE
in standard or Autopilot
mode, as well as
on Anthos and even Cloud Run.
Additionally, you can
orchestrate migration pipelines
to help automate the
migration process.
In this video, we're
focused on the third phase,
so I won't spend a
lot of time here.
The final phase deals with
how you manage applications
after they have been migrated.
Because Migrate for GKE
provides you with the resulting
Dockerfile, you can
easily manage updates
to your code via your
standard deployment pipelines.
Drilling down a
bit into the steps
associated with
that third phase,
and what you'll see
in the upcoming demo,
is the general Migrate
for GKE workflow
when it comes to an
actual migration.
First, we're going to create
a GKE Autopilot cluster.
Then we're going to provide
Migrate for GKE a source VM.
The migration processes
will inspect the VM
and then generate
a migration plan
that we can edit as needed.
From there, it will generate
the deployment artifacts,
including a Docker container.
We'll then deploy that container
onto our Autopilot cluster.
With that, let's
jump into our demo.
We'll start the demo by building
out our Autopilot cluster.
Notice that all I
need to do is provide
a name for the
cluster and the region
in which it's going to run.
And now that our
cluster's up and running,
we can move on to deploying
our sample application.
OK, so let's deploy
the Kubernetes YAML.
And notice that's creating
a bunch of services.
And while they're
created, Autopilot
is increasing the resource
requirements automatically
for us to address
those new services.
Now that that's run,
let's check our pods.
They're still in Pending.
Let's check them again
here a little bit later,
and everything is
up and running.
So we can test the service now.
I'm going to get the
frontend service IP address.
I'm going to navigate
into my web browser.
And you can see here the
application is running.
Let me go in.
I'm going to buy an item, and
then I'm going to check out.
And you see everything
working exactly
as you would expect it to.
The way the application
works is every service
except for the payment service
is running in Kubernetes.
The payment service
is in a VM, and that's
what we're going to migrate.
But first, we need to stop
that VM so we can migrate it.
So let's do that now.
To perform the actual migration,
I switched over to Migrate
for Containers.
And I'm going to click
Create Migration.
I'll give my migration a name.
I'll select a source
that I created earlier.
It's a Linux VM.
We'll give it that VM name.
And we're going to
migrate the image.
With that, I'll click
Create Migration.
And this will go off.
It'll take a little bit of time,
so I'll speed up the video,
and I'll rejoin you
when it's finished.
Our migration is completed,
so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to come
in and I'm going
to review and edit the migration
plan that was generated.
What we're going to
do first is we're
going to come in
and make a change
to this v2kServiceManager
variable and set that to true.
That allows us to use
the enhanced runtime
to run on GKE Autopilot.
And we're going to change
the name of the image
from Payment Service
VM to Payment Service,
and the same thing for
the Kubernetes service,
since it's no longer
running in a VM.
We'll generate our artifacts.
That takes a while, so let
me speed up the video here,
and I'll rejoin you
when it's complete.
So this process is
almost wrapped up.
What we're going to do here
is we're going to take a look,
after it finishes, at the
artifacts that were generated.
You can see we have a
couple of Docker images,
as well as the Dockerfile
and some other artifacts.
I'm going to download
those into Cloud Shell.
So I'll get-artifacts
from my-migration.
If I look in the directory,
you can see those artifacts
that I mentioned previously.
Let's apply the deployment
spec that was generated.
This is going to deploy
our new payment service,
so we'll do a kubectl
apply -f deployment_spec.
That's creating the new
service and the new deployment
in Kubernetes.
Clear the screen,
and let's check
and see the status
of those pods.
This might take a few seconds.
All right, let's just
wait for those to come up,
and we'll speed up the video.
Now that that is up and
running, that new service,
what we're going to
do is we're going
to check our app to see if it
actually is all working again.
So we'll buy this camera.
Add to cart.
Place order.
And everything is working
exactly as expected.
We have migrated the
payment service from the VM
into the container.
I hope that demo
showed you how easy it
can be to not only deploy
a GKE Autopilot cluster,
but also how simple
it can be to migrate
an existing VM-based
workload to Kubernetes.
For more detailed
information, check out
our documentation, as well as
the other videos in our Migrate
series.
And don't forget to
like and subscribe
to be alerted whenever
we publish new content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]